well good afternoon everyone okay we're
gonna try this try it in good to be with
all of you such a such a wonderful day
to see our faculty colleague students
alumni friends and supporters of our
community here to celebrate of course
this day at at CMU so happy to have you
here Tris and I are honored by your
presence before I start I I was told
that during this morning ceremony I had
to just stick to the script it's a
formal ceremony our Abeka got the same
thing as well so we had to be not
anymore oh my gosh again I've already
instructed our panelists our faculty
colleagues are going to be here they can
do anything they want so completely
endorsed by our provost and the deans
and and so on before I go on I want to
make a shameless plug our marketing
communication folks after a couple of
years of trying finally gave me an
Instagram account
I am pretty sure they're already sorry
they've done this but hey too late now
so my Instagram account is at CMU
Farnham at CMU Farnham and it's at CMU
Farnham yeah yeah and and it has 927
followers as of now yeah yeah I know I
know I I personally check each one of
them I know who you are thank you
a thousand is a milestone I would really
appreciate to get to a thousand today
yeah I know it's shameless I know how
much time do we have for this symposium
can go that about four all right I'm
going to stand here until it gets a
thousand yeah furthermore I want to tell
you that there is a new emoji it's the
Farnham emoji
I tried to tell people it looks just
like my brother who's here visiting and
they're insisting it actually it looks
like me
go figure anyway with that good
afternoon I am delighted to welcome you
to this afternoon's inauguration
symposium I hope you all have an
opportunity to enjoy some lunch with us
and enjoy the day
with especially with our students and
colleagues who are all across campus I'm
truly excited for today's program which
covers so many of the areas in which CMU
is at the leading edge you will hear
from faculty and academic leaders from
seven different colleges within the
university all discussing and this is
really important how CMU is deepening
its societal impact here at CMU we are
utilizing our strengths at the
intersection of technology and humanity
to draw important insights from massive
amount of data to enhance communities
through design Arts and Humanities to
apply statistics and mathematics to
solve complicated problems to utilize
the power of robotics AI and automation
to build better tools for cities
communities and classrooms and so much
more what really excites me about today
is that we will get into we will get to
hear first-hand from our faculty
colleagues and researchers who are
making a real world impact through
innovative experimentation and community
focused collaboration this is what CMU's
leadership is all about our first panel
will explore how CMU is working to turn
the city of Pittsburgh into a living
laboratory working to improve the
quality of life for citizens as well as
to spur economic growth in our region
this discussion will be led by our
colleague Marshall Lovett who is
associate vice provost for educational
innovation and learning analytics
director of Everly Centre for teaching
excellence and educational innovation
and a teaching professor of psychology
after a short break we will then
celebrate CMU's impact more globally
with a panel focus on how CMU is helping
to solve major challenges facing society
facing our society around the world that
session will be led by Sarah Mendelson
Distinguished Service professor of
public policy and head of Heinz colleges
program in Washington DC I would like to
invite our first panelist to take their
seat at this stage as I turn the
microphone to Marshall love it so we're
so lucky to have Marshalls leadership at
Carnegie Mellon who has who she's called
the classroom space itself a living
laboratory where teachers work
experiment and adapt to us understand
how the students do their work best and
how they learn best please join me in
extending a warm welcome to Marcia and
our first group of faculty panelists
[Applause]